welcome to this video playing against as
I know no brain pick up that's the
translation of this this name and then
playing the trombone recently I had
scored quite well with that should I
seven who what to do here just cover
crazy for I guess we should be seven
asleep later that often there isn't this
quite quite nice for wide I mean he
might play you five but I can go if I've
myself one way maybe trying to get this
big space advantage in the center and
age for maybe 95 yes but if I now this
is totally ridiculous if I know
sacrifice like take here Bishop age
seven then Bishop e7 95 check is this
totally ridiculous maybe
you can do to h6 this is this is maybe
them the real issue
2g six loads looks dangerous still but
he can go to h6 mmm that's a that's
really disappointing I was hoping that i
can sacrifice but does not seem to work
and I definitely want to keep this
Bishop at the moment I ok so hmm can I
somehow ignore it you can take and play
Knight F for all the time if I play
something like we need to ok so I have
to take it the ganyan i def for ism that
is quite annoying my age for it's not
really fit them into all of that so much
Disko troop the aid coming yeah now this
is mostly to be back we need to a snide
f4 always it was a big issue so maybe i
can way I can play this position somehow
yes syllabus should be selenite f4 mmm
yeah that's really not good here
surprising I thought I should be it
should be at least all right but it
really seems that black has no problems
whatsoever I mean even it's a bit more
comfortable
and not trying to attack here I just
want to cover a form so that this night
is not coming here now it's really
comfortable for black he can if he
really doesn't have any better idea you
can have this kind of thing look see one
no not should not nice or maybe ever
take you five gets week was just see
three he can go to d3 but I don't know
how bad this is I take here a couple of
times if I've as we get the end
yeah that Bishop takes h7 was not
working Willem put my position in some
sort of disarray and it really it really
was necessary to work otherwise my
position is really not any good yeah and
he's playing this well what is he doing
to me here not good just to pawn down
for absolutely nothing and it's a big
central pawn poo okay you have this
check on it I mean it's nothing great
again between the fire for example is
good simply centralizing maybe queen 844
Queenie eight but I'm really just a pawn
down Queenie 8 Queen takes f7 would help
but you can easily cover that but how
exactly if I can just take a seven and
also somewhat back in the game that's a
way to cover it not a very active way
Zach
quindi several years I just have to be
active of course the pawn down in the
Queen and kami surf is not great but
check jf seven is not that easily
protected and when i get this porn on
his king is so not feeling very
comfortable maybe this for Queen f7 now
let's not let's it does not seem so easy
to win
my active Queenie I should give me some
come to play this King is not very
secure at the moment I'm threatening
this perpetual Queen chakma you cannot
do it laughing against it really we
never ate is some check giving away easy
monetary sir I cannot play for win ham I
don't see how check yeah this was really
a really bad out of the opening this is
this should be quite okay for what I
mean I have a good central control but
it seems that this is probably premature
if I especially h5 I cannot sacrifice
then this and this is is really not good
I was thinking that Jesus might be
possible but it seems that here he can
go here to h6 and here I don't see an
attack at all I mean I don't get to this
king sometimes this King edge 6 is not
working after those sacrifice because
there is a bishop on see one that is
helping in the attack but there is no
such bishop anymore so here here i have
no attack and this is really the issue
but probably there is something better I
mean maybe Here I am try to accelerate
the development it takes Queen takes at
least I'm quickly castling long this is
probably better than the game term I
quite quickly got into difficulties here
maybe should still play Queen each I
don't know it's h4 simply out of this
it's not not fitting into this position
and I'm getting I'm getting big trouble
here maybe the Queen d 4 and so on isn't
good to swallow it I don't like the
position here that much I mean this is
Knight to f4 bishop on b7 is really well
placed the bishop on c4 is doing not
much and I don't have any natural move I
if
I have to play something like g3 maybe
actually maybe I should do something
like this let's say something like this
and try to regroup the bishop here this
this is maybe an idea to just just stay
solid but black simply has the better
position here okay thanks for watching